if it's a good film
you can make
more money than what Netflix is going to
offer you in that particular amount of
time and you might even be able to do it
faster
where would you be right now without
Tubi I'm sure I'll be
moving forward with another streaming
service you know it just so happens that
right now two weeks working for a lot of
Independence
and it created a situation where you
don't have to go to
um
a lot of the bigger Networks like the
BTS and
and things like that like you don't like
if you're on Tubi and you your movie is
you know you've built the audience and
your movie is is strong enough the
storyline is strong enough to where
um people
want to watch it
you could actually make more money on 2B
TV than going and getting a license deal
or or selling a movie to BT
over over time you know so
um I think that I think that for me
you know
um
I think that 2B is just something that
it was it was timing because before 2B
it was Amazon
so I just think that it's one of those
scenarios where I got into the movie
industry at the right time
and my film was my first film was done
at the right time
and so I believe that if I wasn't doing
2B it'd be something else because that's
just
what I do
how many movies do you have on 2B
currently
um
currently we have seven projects on
there
so there are circumstances one two three
and four
um untangled
um a good day for everybody
and the rise and fall of cuckoo cow it's
a documentary
and we have a project in post-production
right now all about a check that'll be
out this summer and we got a bunch of
projects slated for production
this year and next year
so more to come okay yeah
how did you get your first movie on 2B
um first movie I got it on there through
uh distributor
so you know in order for you you have a
film on tubing you have to have
some form of distribution
because you can't just submit a movie to
them you have to have either aggregator
or a distributor to get to them
this was what year
that was in 2000
and
um my first movie went on there I want
to say
was it 2018
something like that have you gotten all
of your movies on 2B the same way yes
you have to go to a distributor all of
them all of them and um I have
relationships with a few different
distributors so
you know and that's sometimes that's
good to be able to to figure out what's
the best situation for you right it's no
different than a a music artist who goes
through different labels or Distributors
you have to find the best situation for
you because
what might be the best situation for the
distributor might not be the best
situation for you
and how would a filmmaker know that
that's a good point
well I think you you you would know that
number one
um first of all by by knowing that
they're paying you your money
I think that would be good yeah okay
that's the number one sure number one
and also you would know that by
um
gauging how supportive they are of you
what what type of assets they're
providing you with to help you continue
to move forward so
um what are they
you know what what are are they just
collecting a check or are they actually
there as a partner
as a voice in helping you to say okay
well maybe you should try this and are
they helping you with different
um concepts with marketing
um are they putting up marketing dollars
are they invested in the project with
you ultimately not just saying okay here
give us a movie and you know good luck
hopefully it makes some money right
so I I think for me right now I mean in
every situation it's different you know
if you're trying to get your first movie
out there I think that the biggest thing
is to just get with a distributor that
has some integrity
somebody that's gonna pay you right
that's number one
so but but but as you continue to grow
and develop in anything then that means
you you are going to need more
from your partners right because you're
not going to stay at the same level
as when you first began so I think that
that as a producer you know when you get
to your second third fourth and whatever
movie then you're gonna start to learn
that on your own
it's going to be certain things that's
going to start to click with you it
because if you've made four or five
movies or whatever that means that you
are
you are consistent and obviously you are
serious about what you're doing so if
you did so you're not just making movies
that means there's going to be other
things that you're learning throughout
that process because you don't just make
all of these movies and you're not
taking in retaining no information so I
just think that
you know ultimately to answer that
question I think that it's on the
filmmaker to
to receive the ride as it is and enjoy
the ride
and and be intentional about learning
throughout the process of what you need
and what you don't need
and why not Netflix
well
um Netflix is is obviously a tough for a
platform to get on but Netflix uh
contrary to what a lot of people believe
you know when it comes to Independent
films Netflix is not really
friendly like that with Independence
um you know they they and and and when I
say that I mean that you know what the
licensing deals and what not that they
give out and I'm not trying to buy them
off Netflix I'm just saying that in
terms of
um avod which is advertisement video on
demand which is places like to be
um
Pluto Youtube things like that and then
you have S by which is subscription
video on demand which is your Hulu's
your Netflix's in different places like
that
um
Netflix is S5 and
and Netflix
what they're gonna do is they're going
to license your movie out from you and
they're going to give you a certain
amount of money and more than likely
they're going to want it to be an
exclusive deal meaning that if you give
a new film to Netflix you're a fairly
new producer or you don't have that many
titles you haven't put any you ain't hit
the ball out the park at whatever that
might be
um then
they're gonna offer you a certain amount
of money whatever that might be and it's
not going to be this high amount that
people think so that's why you see a lot
of a lot of producers choosing to go to
a lot of other streaming services
outside of Netflix I mean it's just
simply because when you do the licensing
deal with them they're gonna want to
control that piece of content for a
certain amount of time so that means you
can't put it anywhere else and a lot of
filmmakers are finding out that
especially Independence that
you'll be better off just putting it on
to me and you know
um and cash flowing that way because
over time
you're gonna make
if it's a good film
you can make
more money than when Netflix is gonna
offer you in that particular amount of
time and you might even be able to do it
faster
okay let's say though Netflix if you're
lucky enough to have prominent placement
if people are choosing your film do you
think that's worth it even if it's like
a year contract and then more eyeballs
are on it and then once the contract
expires you know so so more people are
You're Building more awareness with
Netflix definitely I mean listen
um it's all about what goals you have
right
so that could definitely be a situation
where you could give Netflix to film and
they could boost the booster sales up
and they could be strong for you
um I may assuming they could boost up
the the awareness of the film which then
once you get the film back once people
know what it is
they might go click on it right
but
to me that's a gamble because here's the
thing right
how bad do you believe in yourself
so
um do you have the type of
infrastructure and the fan base that
could sustain the same profitability for
that project in that ear
because let's just say you spent 150 000
on this movie or whatever and Netflix
want to license it out for
okay so you make seventy five thousand
dollars right
and then you get you get the brand
awareness and you know you you can now
tell people I have a movie on Netflix
that's cool but
you just would have to look at that as a
producer and just ask yourself what is
your overall goals because that is an
option right but
I mean you might tell yourself
you know what I take this situation
right here just to get in there and
figure out if you can just build the
relationships with them right and then
it might be one of your films where
this might not be one of your biggest
pieces of work or this might not you
might not give them the biggest
um title that you have in terms of you
know you just might give them something
that okay this is an okay film it's a
good film but it's not your best work
right
so I guess ultimately that's just going
to depend on
what do you think
is most important for you at that time
as a producer are you trying to build
relationships
because if you want to build a
relationship with Netflix that's a good
way to get yourself in right and if you
have multiple titles and you know
depending on what you spent on the movie
if if you can turn a profit in that
first year it might be worth it so
I will I would just say that you know
um just the way out all the options
it's great advice does 2B take every
movie
no um to be
um
they take a lot of movies
of course but I think they got over 50
some thousand titles now
but um
they're starting to be more selective
about the quality and one big deal
breaker is the audio
you know
um as the audio and that's that's like
one of the main
things that I've seen recently
um that I've heard from some
Distributors and filmmakers is
you know the audio not passing quality
control
so
um you know at this point Toby is you
know they they've become a household
name so of course initially they was
taking everything right
but now
and now they they built up the catalog
to where they can be more selective
as to what they taken and I would I
would say that you know they're probably
gonna give more strenuous
in terms of what they're picking the
titles that they're picking as they
continue to grow which is understandable
sure so do you do you always think about
that or you know like lav mics ADR
different things like is that something
that you're super
critical love is the audio for your
films yeah audio is is um
audio can make or break a movie
audio can be the difference between
you get in distribution and you're not
getting distribution so that's because
creatively creatively when you're
talking about the picture right so the
the actual story
I mean it's your story to tell however
you want to tell it right
um as long as you don't have any content
in there that's that's like against
the the streaming service against their
overall rules of what they put on their
on that streamer service I mean they
they'll pretty much give you free reign
as to the creativity right but but think
about it the audio is more of a thing
where
is like okay if the listener can't hear
it
then
it's a it's a bad product